[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's time for your fantasy fire true
Wow from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace in Fabulous Las Vegas it's your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
mad
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I made it and I cleaned up well I
think we're just getting ready and now I
am ready for you because it's time for
your fantasy fire drill I am at camp we
are live here in Las Vegas at the Caesar
sports book where you can find us every
single Sunday morning 11:30 Eastern 8:30
Pacific on all of the BR platforms as we
get you're getting ready for week 3 and
Beyond we'll get your questions in a lot
of the injuries to cover we have in and
outs and actives coming down I got
sleepers we've been hot there we're
gonna stay hot is this shirt hot it's up
to you let me know in the comments I
don't know yet my wife's didn't like it
but you might anyway you're not here for
fashion advice you're here for fantasy
advice and that is what I have for you
hit me up in the comments as soon as
we're done any questions I don't get to
I'll jump in there and get your
questions answered I'm holding a
football well why thank you to my
linemen for getting me here but am I
gonna play quarterback in the NFL you're
probably looking for a quarterback right
now
it is time for camp fire talk I know
what's gone on in the last two weeks
really since last month it's Andrew Luck
retired it's not been good for the
quarterback position for us in the
fantasy football world and you might be
nodding your head right now saying yes I
really wish I took Lamar Jackson I
really wish I had one of these
quarterbacks that's actually playing
this week because as we're gonna see and
as many of you know this week has been a
mess at the quarterback position it
started when luck retired last month but
Luck's gone to Brees he's got a bad
thumb Ben Roethlisberger's done till
next year
the Jets down to the third quarterback
the Dolphins
I don't know bring Marino back at some
point it is an absolute mess Cam Newton
is out he is day-to-day who knows it's
gonna happen this week if you haven't
given in to streaming quarterbacks yet
you probably have to now hey I've been
helping you out Matthew Stafford week
one Josh Allen and week two those might
be regular starters now I got another
one coming up for you for week three
embrace streaming the quarterback
position and something I don't want you
to do is to be trading for a quarterback
we'll get to that in a little bit now
it's time for in and outs now here's our
inactives this is what we know as of
right now we will revisit this later on
in the show but we do have some players
that we know we can tell you as we look
at the early games of injuries that
aren't going to be out there today
first we start with the showing Jackson
now we know he is not going to be
playing today very simple here a lot of
people pick it up he'll keep picking up
Nelson Aguilar it might be for just this
week it might be for longer than that
but it's worth playing Aguilar today
against the lines now Alshon Jeffery we
don't have official word just yet
it sounds like he's not going to be out
there today if he does play it is at
less than 100 percent I will give you a
rookie sleeper from the Eagles a little
bit later on and the Dallas got hurt
here currently sounded like it was
better yesterday then it had been I know
he's trying to work out this morning we
don't have that one yet we will update
this board as soon as we get the
official inactive list from the Eagles
obviously playing Earths with confidence
LeSean McCoy is in today he is active
for the Kansas City Chiefs and we know
that Damian Williams he is out today so
that leaves McCoy as the lead back in a
potential rainy game between the Chiefs
and the Ravens now if you read my
sleepers article on Friday you know he
had Darwin Thompson in there I think he
does have some flex value but Damian
Williams is officially out today as we
know McCoy will play he is less than
100% I'd say he's probably in the range
of 15 to 20 at running back this week
I'd call Darwin Thompson a decent flex
option remember they are playing a very
good defense in the Baltimore Ravens now
we move on here if you didn't know Devin
Singletary is out if you want to take a
shot on Francoeur no problem to me has a
chance to be a top 20 running back this
week Mark Andrews today for the
Baltimore Ravens he will play he's a top
5 tight end if you are lucky enough to
have Mark Andrews on your team you have
a player who is one of the few guys that
I would say I would confidently start
every week at the tight end possession
we don't have a lot of those guys Mark
Andrews just become one of those players
and a great story this weekend be our
gridiron about him playing through
diabetes and being able to mentor others
so good guy all around and Mark Andrews
CY Hilton is active today you play him
as you always would marlon mac is also
in today for the coal so some good news
here for the colts in terms of their
injury situations both guys are good and
then James White is out and
congratulations to James white this is
not a bad thing he is about to have a
child so congratulations to him
I will tell you this if you're reaching
real deep for a flex take a look at Rex
Burkhead no James white and as we know
Antonio Brown not a patriot and
apparently he retired or something this
morning who cares we don't have to worry
about him now
late game action we're gonna move into
this board here obviously nothing super
official other than we know that Cam
Newton will be out I will give you the
deepest the deepest bring it in it's the
deepest sleeper I could possibly give
you Kyle Allen he runs they have the
Cardinals I know I'm crazy maybe it's a
second quarterback maybe he's just
extremely cheap in DFS but he is playing
quarterback for the Panthers today all
right he does have Greg Olson by the way
Greg Olson not official but is expected
to play today so you're good to go with
him in a good matchup against the
Cardinals but Cam Newton is out sterling
Shepherd I never assumed anything but
was cleared from the concussion he is
expected to play today get back in the
lineup against the Buccaneers sneaky
good matchup there and then Jordan Reed
is out and the report came out literally
minutes ago and I can't say I'm
surprised
Adam Schefter saying Jordan Reed is
considering retirement a lengthy
unfortunate concussion history for Reed
you don't have to keep him on your
roster my best wishes go out to Jordan
Reed he has had an unfortunate career
when it's come to the concussions now
we'll revisit this board to get some
official things later on when we have
them for the early games but now we jump
into your questions for week three and
possibly beyond let's see what we have
here from those of you looking for some
answers for this week chubber carson
from too many months i'm gonna tell you
to play chump against the rams because i
think it's gonna get some catches today
in addition to his carries nerf baller
Watkins Lockett Tyrell Williams and
Connor I'm gonna tell you to play
Watkins if you want to avoid while he is
off the injured poor James Connor if you
want to avoid that and you want to play
Lockett I have no problem I would play
walkins and Connors Gord Devonta Freeman
I'm gonna go back to Devonta Freeman and
I will tell you this we reassessed
personal depth charts after the third
week we may be doing that with the
Vontae Freeman but I'll play them today
Edelman feeling or Connor flex half PPR
I think I feel safest about Julian
Edelman
you don't have James White as we
mentioned the Antonio Brown not in the
NFL anymore
moving on here from sensing Justin
Jackson do you piste anticipate more
value from him a
take on the Texans I don't think I ever
associated him with volume austin Eckler
has absolutely been crushing it why
would they go away from him
Jay pre emption I start I roll into the
hip winter he was taken you didn't see
him on here why because Tyra Williams
was taken off the injury report
I still think you could play him as a
decent not great wide receiver too and a
tough matchup with the Vikings now we go
to the board we have a video question
from one man to another man
his Matt Brian is still the guy in that
set for his monster gonna start coughing
his caries look I don't know who to pick
here I feel like Cam Newton trying to
select a scarf which one of these is
gonna make me look pretty on Sunday
Kyle Shanahan Kyle Shanahan makes all of
us look pretty because he he's a fantasy
genius now if you had Matt Breda last
week he didn't get over a hundred yards
if you picked up Matt for you to put him
in your lineup and got 100 yards no one
should be cleaning it and come
complaining and that isn't I got a tweet
that someone wanted to complain about
that I gave you a hemostat last week
that hit Jeff Wilson was in the mix this
is why I like to have in Coleman pretty
season because Kyle Shanahan is an
offensive genius and he can make
anything work it's why you might see his
quarterback popping up here in just a
few minutes it's wise Devo Samuel is in
the mix here for this team so I still
think Matt Breda is the guy but I don't
consider him a top 15 back because they
use all of their running backs
now I mentioned his quarterback there
there's indeed time for this lick we
have a doorbell here there's a Defoe
right the door I come through hi good to
see you seem so happy
what's this for cuz of my great sleepers
well kind of it's because every time I
listen to you it makes me want to go to
sleep why why are we clapping is that
for me oh maybe she was being nice last
week sleepers Josh Allen yes look II
Cole Harmon yes and the aforementioned
rahim most earned three for three last
week gave you Stafford a couple weeks
ago gave you Chris Thompson let's see we
have for this week those 49ers the
genius Kyle Shanahan his beautiful
quarterback Jimmy Garoppolo should be in
your lineup today potential top ten
option not only for this week but if
you're hurt with all those quarterback
injuries you might
want to stick with this guy Pittsburgh
Steelers coming to Santa Clara this
afternoon by the way Steelers got ripped
apart by Tom Brady Russell Wilson and I
think Jimmy G has a chance to get them
today so there's a quarterback streamer
sleeper maybe somebody you want to keep
around let's move on though to the wide
receiver position JJ are figga Whiteside
yes that is how you say it I was given
official confirmation on that the rookie
wide receiver who I believe was drafted
by the Eagles to eventually replace out
Sean Jeffrey well we could see him take
a step forward today in terms of a
bigger role I know people are playing
Nelson Aguilar I get it the Lions today
is not a bad matchup I like the way
Wentz is playing it's not great but I
think this kid's got a chance if you're
reaching deep last spot in your lineup a
deep sleepy for me is JJ our single
Whiteside
the rookie wide receiver for the
Philadelphia Eagles now we'll go from a
rookie to the complete opposite end
that's Jason Witt you're going wait
Jason witness sleeper well guess what he
was on a lot of waiver wires this week
people didn't draft him you're certainly
not drafting him for your fantasy
broadcasting team but he has been coming
through and I don't mind the matchup why
as we learned last week what do you do
you follow the Dolphins around and you
want to follow Jason Witten against the
Dolphins today remember
no Michael gallop were hurting at the
tight end position if you are hurt and
take a look at Jason Witten maybe it's
just for one week maybe it's for longer
maybe he catches three three balls for I
don't know 26 yards they'll have a
chance to find the endzone
those are some sleepers for you don't
forget Darwin Thompson in my article
this week devin Smith with the Cowboys I
throw in there and Rex Burkhead as we
found out this morning
why because James White's having a baby
we're having a baby
let's go more questions here for week
number three as we continue to get you
ready daniel Jones lover well
congratulations to you digs are Evans
wide receiver - I like Evans against the
Giants today I think the Buccaneers are
trending in the right direction
Carson non PPR picked to DJ more Tyrell
Williams Emmanuel Sanders Terry
Maclaurin I'll go more against the
Carnales I'm good with that
and I'll go with Emmanuel Sanders who
was having an amazing comeback from that
torn Achilles came through last week for
the Broncos Chris God winner juju I just
said it I think the Buccaneers were
trending in the right direction I know
you got Mason Rudolph now playing
quarterback for the Steelers I'm gonna
play Chris Godwin against the Giants
this afternoon Teddy guy traded Sony
Michelle for Joe Mixon can I get a great
on that trade yeah let's call it a
b-minus that's gonna go either way I do
like Sony Michelle today against the
Jets how good can Josh Allen be fantasy
wise long-term Frank the tank the best
thing happened to Josh Allen we got him
as a streamer now he becomes a regular
player in your lineup he is inside my
top 10 where he could remain for the
rest of the season he's got the legs and
he's got John Brown hitting balls deep
is Chris Herndon still worth stashing if
you need that spot in your lineup for
somebody else or spot in your roster for
somebody else because of the quarterback
issues I would look elsewhere if you
have it keep turning around because he
could find his way into the top 10 all
right we're getting more of your
questions in the app but we're gonna get
more of people here we're in Las Vegas
and we're getting some help out to the
world we got some people watching the
air in the sports book in Las Vegas so
let's get a live question here hello sir
what's your name my name is sexy legs
sexy Lex okay is that your fantasy team
name I'll just assume that's it yes
what's your question
my question is you think the Green Bay
receivers are gonna get back on track
this week good question a lot of people
worried here Matt Lafleur's new offense
may be taking a little time to enact
they're still feeling good about Davante
Adams
I think Alison and mvs that could be one
week it's this guy one week it's the
other guy
I don't play either player with
confidence it might take some time but
you keep rolling with Davante Adams is
gonna be alright good luck to you thank
you there you go
we help out everybody and now yes indeed
you know that sound its iconic I believe
now it's time for a Matz moment two
deals
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
acting I got a whole class to do that oh
okay here's what I'll tell you all that
stuff I was doing don't do that do not I
beg of you micromanage your teams don't
be throwing trades out there all
willy-nilly if you lost the quarterback
tough go stream one go pick one up do
not trade important players in your
starting lineup to get a quarterback you
can go find one I bring this up I'll
bring it up again
Josh Allen outscored Patrick of Homs in
the fantasy playoffs last year you can
find these quarterbacks its Jimmy Graham
its Matthew Stafford heck it could be
Jacoby Bruce at one week it might even
be Daniel Jones at some point if you
have to stream that's okay also do not
trade running back depth now you might
be five Arby's deep and feeling great
you're going to dip into that depth it
happens every single year keep the depth
we're two weeks into the season more
injuries are coming you don't want to
hear that but I'm giving you a piece of
truth hang on to that depth don't
micromanage your teams don't look like
me up there more of your questions here
for week number three we get them
answered as we always do because that's
what this show is all about all right
what do we have here for the questions
we have no questions that's how good
here we go
Kenyan Drake LeSean McCoy or DJ we're
gonna go DJ there for you with McCoy
banged up ZM all right keep it going
here next question is Jay last pick to G
juju locket or Robinson some weather
concerns there for the Chiefs will sit
Robinson this week in that matchup let's
go to this is Brady oh you would have a
lot to say on Twitter the other night
what do you do with the case you
receivers Hardman Robinson if there's
heavy rain those were flex players to me
anyway that's where they can remain if
you're playing them is anything more
than that I think you're kind of
guessing flex is at best if you want to
break a tie and take him out because the
rain no problem with that
Irish oak trade Josh Gordon for Darren
Waller not a bad idea two weeks ago not
something I do now Antonio Brown thank
goodness out of New England Josh Gordon
back to the wide receiver to maybe wide
receiver three conversation going
forward don't make that trade
let's see D be four five six o Garofalo
or May
field I have them neck-and-neck I think
I have a little bit more trust and
Garoppolo base in the matchup I think
Baker ceiling is high if you are an
underdog right now go with Baker
Mayfield start caller Murray or Russell
Wilson I like the volume that Murray
should get against Carolina so I'm okay
going with him now we go to a viewer
celebrity whatever this guy is let's see
his question Mary camp listen people out
there i text matt camp my fantasy
questions but today i'm coming live and
in person that's right adam Lefko from
ditch the playbook matt camp I have all
J Howard all my fantasy team I took him
in the fifth round he's on the field
almost every play 55 snaps zero targets
he's saying I got to do a better job
Bruce Arians says we gotta get on the
ball but I don't believe him how many
more weeks do I let this play before I I
cut bait what do I do
man is he done could left go talk
anymore than that watch ditch the
playbook listen to the left go podcast
it's my show Adam by the way I think
you're on Star Trek with that shirt
whose shirts better miner left goes and
he did by the way literally just text me
before the show well what about OJ
Howard I think the Buccaneers are
trending in the right direction Howard
is out there I know the Bruce Arians
history Bruce Arians is not an idiot he
has a talent to tie down and OJ Howard
the Buccaneers are trending the right
way and well like we said you wait three
weeks you reassess your personal depth
chart OJ Howard has the Giants today you
give them another shot and go watch this
to PlayBook all right now we have
updates from the inactives let's get to
those right now first of all we know
DeSean Jackson is out simple as that you
were playing Aguilar anyway Alshon
Jeffery will not play today and then
Dallas Cotter if we have an update on
that art so Goddard is in Goddard is not
a bad deep tight end play not 100% but
with Jackson out and Jeffery out
Aguilar's got top 25 potential and I
would say my sleeper JJ our single
Whiteside the rookie wide receiver he's
gonna be in the starting lineup he
played a bunch of snaps last week
against Atlanta that's a deep sleepy
that makes sense against the Detroit
Lions
LeSean McCoy these we know already he is
in he is not a hundred percent the
matchup is tough it's in the rain
against Baltimore but
Damien Williams is out some McCoy's in
that 15 to 20 range for me at running
back and then Darwin Thompson who's in
my sleepers article does have some flex
potential so no Damian Williams but we
do have LeSean McCoy
now Devin Singletary we know is out for
the bills today we do have Frank Gore
who's got some top 20 potential he'll
get plenty of carries there Mark Andrews
is gonna play through his injury he's a
top 5 option until further notice
against the Chiefs I'm surprised he's
good to go with the rain but they're
happy to get him out there Hilton Marlon
Mac are both in for the Colts you
continue to play them as wide receiver 2
and running back twos respectively and
then James White is out for a good
reason
expecting a baby going into labor so we
won't have James White Rex Burkhead
a deep sleepy as a flex option in PPR
formats now let's look at our late game
and Monday list of players obviously
nothing is official other than what we
know is declared Cam Newton is out Kyle
Allen Kyle Allen remember the name deep
sleepy use the legs cheap on DFS Greg
Olson expected to play for Kyle Allen
who will have obviously DJ Moore who
will have curtis samuel sterling
sheppard was cleared from his concussion
should be fine good to get him back in
the lineup for young daniel Jones and
Jordan Reed as we found out today not
only is he out but according to Adam
Schefter he is thinking about retirement
keep firing up Terry Maclaurin with
confidence alright
I think we got everything covered which
means it's time for the speed round
[Music]
so the workouts there at the pool sardar
those who have to watch it but i think
they paid off we hit a new number coach
let's do it baby this week we got to get
14 put this on on my um top are you a
about things i do a photoshoot this week
and yell and all that stuff
Calvin Ridley or Hollywood Brown will go
really will stay away from brown with
the weather against the Chiefs today
that's one let's keep it going
Amari Cooper Emmanuel Sanders as good as
Sanders is playing you got to fire up
Cooper with confidence against to the
Miami Dolphins trade Mike Thomas and
Myles Sanders for feel and Olsen and
Maclaurin I don't want to trade Mike
Thomas just yet so no don't make that
trade keep it going start Kyle Allen or
Jacoby Brissette alright I'm gonna put
my money where my mouth is play Kyle
Allen today and then come back and thank
me or hate me
whatever Sean says PPR flex Samuel or
devin Smith Samuels probably a little
bit safer if you're a big underdog
I could see Smith hit and yet another
big play against the Miami Dolphins
River no Michael gala for the Cowboys
Mike Williams debo or Randall Cobb I'll
go with Mike Williams I know he's not a
hundred percent but they had the Texans
and that matchups pretty good rich 30
should I trust Connor this week after is
the injury rich I'll tell you this you
can't ignore it but they took him off
the injury report that's good enough for
me
you can trust Connor as a top way
they're doing for the kids with the kids
that's exactly who's watching this show
c'est quand four Keenan Allen a Tyree
kill village here general advice do not
have injury optimism that's having
injury optimism for Tyree kill and it's
training the best player in fantasy
football will do it don't make that
trade akka aka that's the thing to PPR
to Robertson John Brown a Cooper Cup
simple never bench Cooper Cup you will
regret it and I would play John Bryan
over Allen Robinson this week Nick T
dagger mahomes PPR Nick you have a trade
to make someone will give you a lot for
one of those quarterbacks
I'm never benching Patrick mahomes Chad
Superflex monster Chuck here's another
general piece of advice in the Superflex
you always play a quarterback because
it's much easier to get the points even
in bad game so Wentz over Chubb their
cough or wince I'm going went but only
by a little bit and I know God has the
Browns with the issues with their
secondary coffins are upside play Wentz
is your safe play come on let's go
Shepard or Alan Robinson I'm happy
Shepards back but you're playing Alan
Roberts in the big a 325
keep it going gore Terri Maclaurin for
iceberg slim I can't bench Maclaurin
right now and I know boards gonna get
plenty of touches Maclaurin it's
absolutely rolling
Larry Fitz where's Carolina he went
against Oakley I'm playing Adam feeling
sorry that's we're going with simple as
that and I know if it's a salad feelings
a big time player we're playing field
against Oakland did I do it that's a
winner that's a winner I'm a winner put
are you a winner if you listen to me
hopefully you are I got to a lot of
questions there and throughout the show
but if I didn't I'm jumping in the app
for the next thirty minutes and we're
gonna take as many questions as we can
to get you ready for week three and
beyond and if you don't know now you
know you're here every Sunday 11:30
Eastern 8:30 Pacific for your fantasy
fire drill we're here in Las Vegas if
you're in town come out maybe I'll get
you on the mic if not make sure you join
us tell your friends your family this is
where it is this is where you need to be
to get your advice every single Sunday
morning good luck to everybody in week
number three i'm matt camp this has been
your fantasy fire drill